quand l'afld a bu un coup de rouge
depuis longtemps quand on revoit et ben
on apprécie voici jean le cam marin
breton au palmarès impressionnant
à 61 ans il boucle son cinquième vendée
globe le tour du monde à la voile en
solitaire et sans escale c'est la magie
du vendée globe on appelle ça et c'est
vrai qu'avant simple après cela encore
d'abord équipier d'eric tabarly au début
des années 80 il prend le large dès 1985
le cam à 26 ans il vient de remporter la
dernière étape de la solitaire du figaro
une course en solitaire et par étape sa
marque une étape du figaro c'est bien
réussi à gagner le cam fini deuxième au
général derrière philippe poupon 1994 il
remporte enfin la solitaire du figaro
le marin arrive en pleine nuit le cas
mais complètement épuisé après trois
semaines de bataille acharnée c'est ça a
été un moment quand même c'est assez
difficile mais je vais terminer puis et
puis ça se termine bien
je fais deux fois 1 2 x 2 je crois que
cette reprise 1996
le breton récidive deuxième victoire sur
le figaro jusque devant michel
desjoyeaux
à l'arrivée pas de confettis ni de
trompette
ce qui étonne jean le cam comme n'y a
pas de coup tu n'as pas de trompette ce
truc
ben on sait pas quand tu dis mais
attends j'ai fait quelque chose de mal
normalement quand y'a pas un coup de
canon au ghana pas un coup de trompette
une ligne d'arrivée c'est que tu es
paraît
à 37 ans jean le cam fait partie des
plus grands
mais le breton ne s'arrête pas là 2004
il se lance à l'assaut du vendée globe
toujours décontracté avec des bateaux à
voile faut toujours essayer d'aller plus
vite que l'autre
jusque là tout va bien pour sa première
participation le cam arrivent deuxièmes
6 heures seulement derrière un autre
breton vincent riou deuxième finistérien
c'est vrai en plus deuxième de port la
forêt 2008
le loup de mer remet les voiles deuxième
participation au vendée globe et grosse
frayeur son bateau se retourne au large
du cap horn
le marin est sauvé par son ami vincent
riou malgré la situation le roi jean
garde son humour ce vendée globe 2021
jean le cam s'apprête à franchir la
ligne d'arrivée
le doyen de la course est devenue la
star de cette édition
après avoir secouru un concurrent en
décembre
le bateau de kevin escoffier s'était
plié en deux au large de l'afrique du
sud
[Musique]